this video is sponsored by raycon
earbuds and will begin right after a
short message
[Music]
everyone needs a good reliable pair of
earbuds especially these days
that's exactly why raycon's newest pair
of everyday e25 earbuds is so popular
with their all new noise isolating fit
coupled with their bass boosting audio
technology it's crazy that they aren't
more expensive than they are
coming in at just about half the price
of well-known competitors
their battery life lasts up to six hours
at a time and they even come with a
charging case that holds up to four
complete charges
plus they come in some really cool
colors if you're interested in getting a
pair of your very own
perfect for listening to music or
podcasts or working out or whatever
you're into
click the link in the description below
or go to www.buyraikon.com
mnb for a whopping 15 off your order
it's only around for a limited amount of
time so what are you waiting for
and now on to the video
so summertime is here actually it's
nearly gone but it's got me thinking
about how much fun
water is
well i suppose it's not quite as fun for
people being drowned to death but hey at
least they got to cool off a bit from
this hot summer sun am i right but
speaking of
you know death by water back in the wind
waker spoiler alert it's explained to us
by the word of daphna's
hansen hyrule the last king of hyrule
that the old hyrule was flooded by the
gods above when ganon busted out of his
seal as he is known to do when he gets
bored now
to be clear this is the same hyrule that
our best boy hero of time saved as an
adult
this hyrule to be specific heck that's
even a statue of him right there and
these are portraits of the sages from
ocarina of time
and the gods i guess not really knowing
what else to do saw
ganon and decided screw it flood him and
just killed everyone
this has for a long time been a very
dark and confusing and
weird part of zelda lore that everyone
begrudgingly accepts since
after all the king said that's what
happened the gods quite literally
committed
genocide when they've never done
anything like that before or since even
though the world has faced
potentially greater threats i mean yeah
some of the populace was instructed to
flee to mountaintops
but you're kidding yourself if you think
everybody made it to a mountaintop
especially with how
tiny they're shown to be in game but
that was then
nowadays hyrule looks like this with an
alarming lack of
you know flood water it's kind of one of
those elephant-to-the-room types of
questions that everyone's afraid to
answer since it's impossible to answer
this without also making a statement as
to which
timeline breath of the wild sits in and
it's a very scary thing to talk about
for sure
since the game references literally all
timelines but the reason why i'm
focusing on the great flood is because
that's really the only
event catastrophic enough across the
entirety of the history of hyrule that
left an impact
big enough to absolutely be felt in
every game following
every game following in its own timeline
of course you see at the end of the wind
waker spoiler warning here again by
the way in fact just know that if you
click on a theory video there will be
spoilers
also you should totally subscribe that
would be super cool because you're super
cool and i'd love it if you stuck around
anyway the hyrule we know and love is
washed away under a few million gallons
of water
and the land of new hyrule is
established through discovery
all well and good but here's the problem
with that the new hyrule doesn't have
the temple of time from ocarina of time
the new hyrule doesn't have the spring
of earth from skyward sword or the
koroks or zora or hyrule castle
yeah breath of the wild's hyrule is
pretty obviously
not the new hyrule established prior to
spirit tracks
now of course this is easily explained
by simply saying breath of the wild
doesn't take place in the adult timeline
right i mean if it took place in the
child or fallen timelines then there's
no problem at all because there's no
flood right
well yes but also no unfortunately due
to the nature of breath of the wild
its placement within the zelda timeline
as before mentioned
cannot ever perfectly fit in any one of
the timelines without also touching on
the histories of the other timelines
even though you might be tempted to
place breath of the wild in the fallen
timeline due to
oh several different reasons like the
appearances of fallen timeline enemies
such as lionel's or the stripe in link's
hat if you're a matpat fan
it's pretty hard then to explain why
zelda knows about the twilight realm
from the child timeline
or why the zora aren't mindless monsters
like they always are in the fallen
timeline and above all that stuff
some really hard obstacles to tackle are
the existences of the koroks
and rito who both only ever appeared in
the adult
timeline never in any of the others
unless you count this sculpted piece
here from twilight princess but i
digress
the biggest call out to the whole hey
this place used to be flooded concept is
the appearance of the rock salt found
all over the land of hyrule emphasis on
all over the land of hyrule not like
from what used to be a sea down in the
gerudo area
no there is literally rock salt found in
every biome that has descriptive text
that reads that it was left there by the
quote ancient sea the ancient sea
all over hyrule you see finding stuff
like this in real life is pretty normal
but anybody who knows even elementary
level knowledge of mineral placements
understands that salt isn't found just
anywhere especially not on the side of a
freaking mountain for instance
no the most common reason for finding
salt just out in the middle of nowhere
in real life is due to the evaporation
of what was once
standing salt water standing
salt water guys so far this video is
barely even a theory
there's just no way around it but i've
read comments over the past three years
that claim that the sea salt being
present in every climate around hyrule
is somehow actually not indicative of
there being a sea that placed the salt
there even though it literally says so
in the flavor text for rock salt
talk about swimming in denial am i right
but that's really only half of what i
wanted to talk about in this video
the fact that i believe there's no way
that this very hyrule and these very
fields were not once
completely underwater the second thing
that i wanted to talk about is
doesn't that solidify its adult timeline
placement
how do we get around that the flood only
happened in the adult timeline and even
more than that in the games following
the flood
civilization left hyrule gone to the new
hyrule
nobody lived in regular old watery
hyrule except for i don't know probably
one of those freaky japanese spider crab
things that walk in the bottom of the
ocean
so the question is twofold if this is
post flood hyrule
how did the waters drain and why did it
become civilized once again to be honest
with you breath of the wild gives us
no hint or clue that would help our
questions here except for one
thing the map have you ever thought it
was a little weird that hyrule seems to
be kinda surrounded by a giant basin
like a huge moat almost pretty peculiar
if you ask me
game designed to limit players adventure
space is one thing but making a giant
valley bordering the northern and
western sides of hyrule as opposed to
just implementing
an invisible wall like there is in
gerudo desert makes me think this is
actually more
deliberate and when you take a look at
the weird damn like rock wall structure
located in the northeastern corner of
the map it really starts to look
well carved like someone came back here
dove deep under the great sea
located the old hyrule and found a way
to drain the waters from its buried
surface
whatever happened and whoever did it
took place well over 10
000 years ago so it's no wonder that
there's a lot of weathering and wear and
tear that's occurred since then
you know a cool thing to think about is
the fact that we know gannon resurrected
after the events of the wind waker since
he's
here now but when we last saw him he was
at the bottom of the ocean
in old hyrule i mean what if he's the
one that somehow surfaced hyrule once
again
since we know that's all he really
wanted in the wind waker what if he
either by using his powers or his
minions or both
resurfaced the old hyrule and somehow
was able to influence the populace of
the world to create a civilization here
once more
what if this is all his doing because at
the end of the day
he still wants the same thing he wants
the land of hyrule
old hyrule his hyrule and the stubborn
undying demon that he is literally
pulled it from the depths to reclaim
what is
unrightfully his god admit it does sound
pretty cool
oh and about the timeline placement i'm
not saying it is solidified in the adult
timeline
but what i am saying is that it can't
not be
you know just to be confusing but i
don't want to turn this into an official
breath of the wild timeline placement
theory so i'm actually
going to stop it right there but if you
would like me to theorize on where
breath of the wild might take place in
the timeline
and add my theory to the rather lengthy
list of already existing placement
theories or if you have a theory let me
know in the comments below
also thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed please consider dropping a like
to spread this video to other fans like
you and me and subscribe to stick around
for the next one this one was kind of a
half theory half ramble video that i
don't know i kinda really enjoyed making
huge thanks as always to my fantastic
supporters of which i have a name to
welcome
say hello to fusion gamers who decided
to join up with my channel and help make
the next video come true by clicking
that join button right here on youtube
thanks so much guys enjoy your benefits
and if you watching are interested
feel free to check out the join button
or the links in the description below to
find out how
also down there are my links to social
media
that was your cue to follow me on
twitter for real though come say hi
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is mass intended bandit
signing out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you